I tell a lot of people like what's the
worst thing that's going to happen the
job's going to say no well then you move
on what's going to be the worst that
happens that boy or girl says no they
don't want to go on a date with you
what's the worst thing that's going to
happen you're going to make 50 videos
nobody watches and you're going to do
something else like people create this
fear of judgment that doesn't exist hey
everybody uh welcome to another episode
of the garyvee audio experience uh been
really trying to be selective and
creative with our guests uh I think
we've got a really good one for you uh
today uh we're gonna Yap hopefully
Inspire
um and uh and and most of all get you to
think and feel and so uh I'm gonna allow
my guests to introduce himself uh tell
you who he is and two minutes about him
and then I'm gonna dig right into it so
Dia I'm excited you're on the show how
are you hey Gary I'm great man thanks
for having me on man it's uh it's truly
an honor to get to meet you I'm sure you
hear that a lot but you're a Trailblazer
and uh look man uh Gary Damon West here
man and I'm telling you it's uh I got
out of prison about seven and a half
years ago and since then I've been out
there sharing my message the story of
The Coffee Bean which we're going to
talk about today and that message is
caught fire all over the world brother
and I appreciate you letting me come on
your podcast today to share this message
with your audience because I truly think
we're going to enrich the lives of
millions of people today so let's get
right into it tell everybody oh you know
two three minutes on you like how'd you
grab let's go way back like where where
were you born what kind of kid were you
and then let's get into the meat of the
story and then get into the meat of the
message yeah I mean I grew up in this
little town called Port Arthur Texas
Port Arthur's down by Louisiana and
Texas on the Gulf Coast came from a
great family uh had everything going for
me in life good athlete uh great athlete
actually I got a scholarship to play
division one college quarterback
University of North Texas uh got injured
in college and went off to work in
different jobs like worked in Congress
worked for a guy running for President
worked on Wall Street uh it was there
that job as a broker in 2004 that I was
introduced to meth for the first time
and it took about 18 months from the
introduction of meth into my system to
lose it all to give it all away Gary
because that's what addicts do we give
things away man I gave up my job my home
my car my savings account my family my
tethering to God and I went from working
on Wall Street to living on the streets
of Dallas Gary and that's when I became
a criminal I was a meth addict and I was
the ringleader of a bunch of other
methods into people's homes and that is
a good place for us to launch and start
the story today actually before we do
that brother because I think you know
the modern technology allows people
obviously that's a very intriguing
starting point I think a lot of people
can pause their podcast Google your name
and probably see you talk about that
part I actually especially knowing this
audience
actually want to double click into
something that just caught my attention
go talk to me about when did you think
that you were going to be or when did
you realize that you were a very
talented athlete
and did you at any point think you were
going to be a professional athlete
or
how much did you being a good athlete
Define who you were you know you know
I'm in the athlete business with Vayner
Sports I know exactly what part of the
country you grew up in that Friday
Friday Night Lights was a very
successful sitcom so I think a lot of
people listening not in a sports
business can probably have a good sense
of what being the star quarterback
of a high school team uh in that part of
the country means I get the luxury of
seeing you right now I know a lot of
people are listening some will watch
videos but I can see you so I can tell
that you were clearly also a handsome
stock as a school year in high school I
want to go into identifying as something
at a young age and how big of a
vulnerability that could be so I I just
yapped a lot let's break this down when
did you realize you were good at sports
Gary great questions and you're getting
right to the heart of it uh when I first
realized I was really good at sports I
was about 11 or 12 years old God blessed
me with a cannon for our right arm and
you and you hit them you hit the nail on
the head man this is Texas man yeah
Friday Night Lights Texas high school
football this stuff is a religion down
here where I live man and and I was the
man I was a three-year starting
quarterback for a five a school biggest
division it was [__] back then boot
chip was like the real big thing to me
it was like they have the star system
now yeah of course but um yeah so being
a quarterback was everything it's how I
identified in life and
because I was such a good athlete I got
away with a lot of things in life Gary
yeah a lot of the rules didn't didn't
apply I'm sorry yeah a lot of the rules
didn't apply to me Gary I I was able to
skate by with things my behavior never
really got checked and I'm not blaming
anybody for that but that's just what
you're not blaming that you're not
blaming the school you're not blaming
your parents no absolutely not the coach
there's nobody but you know what in
hindsight being the byproduct of that
let's just jump because I want to make
this very valuable for the parents that
are listening at home right now who
either have a straight A student and
that's the religion
who have a great you know everyone the
alcaraz match just happened so tennis is
on a lot of people's mind have a great
tennis player and that's their religion
football you know whatever it is how
much do you now realize
that
creating boundaries is obnoxiously
healthy oh it's it's incredibly healthy
and here's what I realized about about
that now and I didn't pick up on this
when I was a late teenager or in my 20s
because you were the beneficiary of it
at the time you were pumped that you
could skip class or you could drink with
your buddies or whatever the [__] you're
about to say but now you understand like
nobody holding you accountable led to
you subconsciously and then consciously
realizing you could get away with [__]
oh yeah and it's Gary even more than
just cutting class I mean I mean I got
pulled over drunk I got all kinds of
things happened to me that would have
put somebody in the criminal justice
system long before I went in there when
I was 33 years old man but but because I
was the quarterback because I could
throw a football you know my identity
Gary was wrapped up in being a college
football player and and the danger about
this and I'm talking to all the parents
and even young people out there is that
when you attach your identity into
something external something you can
attach to you're setting yourself up for
a enormous failure Gary you know this
man you you can't attach yourself to a
job your your athletic ability the
Cardinal job you were you were so kind
to me before we got on camera and then
immediately repeated it like when I tell
you that I have no feelings
towards my professional success you'd be
baffled I'm on the other side of the
fence on this I don't give a [__] that
I'm garyvee I don't give a [__] that I'm
good at making money as an entrepreneur
I think none of that
means anything and no one should treat
me in any shape or form different
because I have a lot of followers or I'm
good at making money or I say nice
things I I just know and I've known
since I was 10. this is why I was a bad
student I was a bad student because I
didn't feel attached to needing to get
A's and B's I love that you're going
down this path
it's I this is why I'm double clicking
on this like I know that you're about to
say a bunch of great [__] but I also
assume because you've had a lot of
success that we can see a lot of that
[__] on the internet because like it's
the same with me that you can see my
core principles out there every day what
we're talking about you and I right now
is actually going to change the course
of five or six people's lives out of the
hundred thousands that are listening
right now or over the course of the next
couple years because it's those early
days of attaching to something it's not
just the Star Quarterback this is why
I'm so scared of school being an Ivy
league student those kids are failing
left and right every day as well in
their 20s and 30s because all they
wanted to be was a straight A student go
to Ivy League and then you're 22 and now
what yeah absolutely and you're and
you're wise Gary in your life to not
attach yourself to anything that's going
on in the world that you've created with
your successes because man that's not
what it's about look Gary I have this
healthy perspective now on what a bad
day looks like and I think that we all
have perspective when a bad day looks
like but when we're wrapped up in this
world we don't even live in a reality
when we're attached to this fake
identity that could be coming from
social media it could become from the
sports we play and look I speak to
college football teams all over America
I've met a lot of your players man
you've got some great guys that you
represent and and I think that the the
danger of that is is that when you
attach yourself to something external
you set yourself up for enormous failure
in my life today Gary every day that I
wake up and my feet don't hit the cold
concrete floor of a prison cell I'm
winning I'm gonna have a good day and it
doesn't matter if I'm out there speaking
on some stage or or writing books or
doing whatever I'm out there making a
positive impact but I didn't understand
that Gary when I was when I was in in
the middle of it man and whenever I'm
going through this living in Texas
everything is available to me that I
want to do but on on September 21st 1996
Gary the entire world changed for me I
call this a fork on the road in life and
and life's about these fork in the road
days these very pivotal days where you
get knocked down you get back up you
dust yourself off but you're going to
make a decision at the fork in the road
you're either going to make the right
choice and go the right way or the wrong
choice and go down the wrong direction
September 21st 96 Gary we're playing
against Texas A M it's a beautiful
Saturday in College Station Texas I'm
20. I'm the starting quarterback for a
division one team at 20 years old period
I'm driving my team down just for fun
who was this who was the opposing
quarterback
I don't remember who the opposing
quarterback is I can tell you who the
opposing linebackers were Keith Mitchell
and that Winn yeah yeah
oh I played against that was the game
that I played against that weight in
fact that tackled me on a couple plays
before this third play of this game Gary
I'm driving my team down the field
against the Aggies in College Station
packed house beautiful Saturday
afternoon and one little boy growing up
in Texas doesn't even want to want to
play for these guys or against these
guys right and there I am driving my
team down the field third play of the
game I'm down on the ground and don't
get back up it's a career in an injury I
separate my shoulder that day and I
never played college football again and
when I get up to this fork and rodent
life at 20 years old and football is
gone at my identity was Gone with it and
Gary I'll get through for a lot of
people listening a lot of sports fans a
separated shoulder in 96 is different
than it is today first of all modern
medicine but second of all I assume that
means on your right shoulder your
throwing arm or you know and what it
just didn't heal well or did you not
rehab properly break it down for me yeah
here's what happened so I separated my
shoulder and my dad was a sports writer
for 50 years down in Port Arthur Texas
Jimmy Johnson is also from Port Arthur
Texas my dad Jimmy are best friends and
so Jimmy sent me to the NFL quarterback
surgeon a guy named Dr vanderbeer in
Dallas Texas and Vandermeer goes in they
they cut my collarbone out they're just
still clavicle because it's popped
through it's got a third degree
separation and I start healing and
coming back in the spring and the off
season and then June of the next year I
I cut my achilles 10 in half so I never
got to play college football again Gary
that game against Texas A M I thought I
could make a comeback and and I was
coming back in the in the in the
quarterback room in the spring but the
next summer I sever my achilles tended
in half and did you did you did that
mentally again as you know even the mid
90s one could conceivably come back to
that or are you telling me after all the
work you put in right you're in the QB
room you're 20 you're staying away from
the fun you're focused it was that
Achilles that was like [__] this
you know I would I'd like to be able to
say I stayed away from the fun and I was
focused but honestly man in my story and
and my autobiography talks about this
the change agent we talk I talk about in
there a lot uh I was a wild guy back in
college Gary I partied I was in a
fraternity I you know I did the
fraternity thing when I was in there
yeah and when that happened it broke me
man I was done with trying to because
the rehab to come back from Achilles
injury it just seemed like a path too
steep for me you were just like [__] it
I'm just gonna be a college kid and have
fun I'm gonna make money but the good
the good news is that the coach kept me
on scholarship man he didn't have I ran
into Gary the other day I run into my
old college coach in the airport a guy
named Daryl Dickey he used to be the
offensive coordinator at Texas A M and
now he's a uh he's an analyst at
University of Georgia he runs into me at
the airport man I take a picture with
this guy he's like my hero because this
guy keeps me on scholarship for the next
two years he doesn't have to that's a
valuable scholarship for a school like
North Texas man we're dude we're
planning to get some of the biggest guys
in the country Alabama LSU all these
schools and he keeps one of those 85
scholarships from me who lives a less
than a desirable life but he understands
that if he cuts me loose that there's no
telling what happens to Damon West back
in 1997 or 1998 so he keeps me on
scholarship until I graduate and I'm
Gary I'm I'm a kind of a pitiful person
at that point I've got a lot of talent
obviously God blessed me with the
ability to talk to people and and get
out and and get out there and get good
jobs like I said I worked in the United
States Congress after college I work for
a guy running for president United
States raising money I was a political
fundraiser raising money all over
America you not only had a Canon right
arm you also had Gift of Gab and
Charisma which was good for a lot of fun
but was also good in those early 20s in
that transition to set you up for
opportunities because that is a
massively god-given Talent by the way to
all the kids that are listening right
now your charisma and ability to talk is
a a monster monster talent and sometimes
you guys and girls downplay that don't
obviously you've got to back it up with
the stake to that Sizzle but it is do
not downplay Charisma it's no different
than being born super funny super
attractive super motivated super
athletic it is one of the other pillars
of god-given talent one that Society
does not talk enough about Charisma is a
big deal yeah and it's it's a muscle you
can work too by the way Gary you 100 you
can get better at it and look
just a little side note man I talk to
people all the time they're like hey man
I you know I want to be more outgoing
but I have this fear of Confrontation or
this this fear to get out and talk to
people listen
I do things I'm afraid of so I can do
things I'm afraid of the more you
address these fears and deal with that
especially speaking to people and being
you know out front and outspoken the
better you get at it but I was born with
that though Gary yes you were born with
that gift but you also lived a life that
got you to places of adversity which
then put things into perspective I tell
a lot of people like what's the worst
thing that's going to happen the job's
gonna say no well then you move on
what's going to be the worst that
happens that boy or girl says no they
don't want to go on a date with you
what's the worst thing that's going to
happen you're gonna make 50 videos
nobody watches and you're gonna do
something else like there's a people
create this fear of judgment that
doesn't exist
it's in their head 100 it's all in your
head and that voice in your head is
usually fear Gary A lot of times that's
fear I I don't listen to myself Gary I
talk to myself I used to listen to
myself I went down to Poor Pitiful roads
because I listened to myself but you
know Gary yeah you're right I was
blessed with the ability to talk to
people and that was something that got
me into a lot of doors like I said you
know United States Congress worked for a
guy running for president Wall Street
back in 2004 I was back in Dallas
training to be a stockbroker for UBS one
of the biggest banks in the world
but it was at that job as a stock broker
in 2004 Gary that that my life and the
lives of a lot of other innocent people
would forever be changed and and look I
was before you go there
I before we go into how meth got into
the system and all that that you set us
up with
was yours and this is so damn important
big moment in the podcast was your
decision to go to Wall Street 2004 96
you were 20 so you're 28 at this point
or so
2004 yeah 28.
was was it now hey I want to make as
much money as possible and wall Street's
a thing you nailed it dude the vices man
I just wanted I just wanted to I wanted
to party I wanted something that would
support a lifestyle of partying and
hanging out making money I mean yeah at
that age Gary I didn't understand the
important things in life
one of the reasons why I like your
content I'm gonna back up a little bit
and talk about something I've learned
from you is you and an entirely
different path You Realize by the time
you were young that you were meant to do
something bigger you took your dad's
wine business and you blew it up you
were doing things in your 20s that now
in my 40s I'm I'm able to start making
those roads but I was late to the game
Gary I was late to the game because I
got distracted yeah the good news is
look and by the way for all the kids
listening home I would argue I went a
little too far because at 47 48 years
old there's certain things I didn't
develop I probably didn't get enough fun
out of the system like listen there's a
great Russian saying that translates to
everything's at its best when it's
balanced right yeah and I think to your
point I was on one extreme where like
listen I'm thrilled and pumped with
every aspect of my life knock on wood
and one of those is why the question
always becomes why why did you want to
party and things you know I always think
like first of all I think that's
incredibly normal I think anybody of the
age of 15 to 30.
has some percentage of them you know
some is 10 some 100 that wants to hook
up that wants to party that wants to be
popular like that's normal human
behavior
but when you start going through the
path
unfortunately too many people want to do
it because they don't have
self-confidence and they don't love
themselves
and they need that drug of others liking
them and all those vices and then for me
I think I went a little bit too far like
I I'm proud to say this and I think
people that go to vcon or really know me
like I think I love my parents like
probably a little bit too much
right and so for me I was obsessed with
I had a sense that I had a talent as
well and I was gonna milk that in my 20s
to do big for my parents because I
always was very grateful that they
raised me well and took me out of the
Soviet Union to America and I was I've
been always grateful always grateful and
so
um that's kind of how my story played
out but I think the balance of the two
as people are listening I don't want
them to over correct into my direction
because I think you know it would have
been okay in my 20s to go on a vacation
for a week like that would have been
okay everything would have been still
fine I think to your point like you you
can't have fun but you can grow up the
best part is 40s is still young I'm
pumped that you have your whole life in
front of you
you know all of a sudden when you're 80
that window of 15 to
28 or to 35 or whatever window you're
about to explain us that's going to be a
small blimp right now it's still a big
percentage of your life this is what I
want I want people to get excited in
their 30s 40s 50s and 60s to realize
when you're 90 15 years was a small blip
you're on that path now
absolutely and it's never too late it's
never too I turn around I was like you
were I was listening one of your
podcasts the other day and you were
talking to the to the other guy you were
talking to about you know the stuff
you're even doing now you're you're
looking forward to the stuff you're in
40 years from now you know I'm in such a
weird place I know we're bouncing around
here but like this is going to get you
pumped and I think this will bring value
this is why I'm jumping in
I kind of weirdly Make Pretend I've done
nothing like that's how I talk to myself
I'm like I love it man I do the same
thing it's called the rookie mindset I
got a real mindset I'm kind of like okay
cool but like
not really like [__] it it's all gone
today's day one and like let's go
[__] Crush anyway I want to actually
hear because this is sexy now like this
is fun for people that like a little you
know Hollywood stuff like okay cool
you're 28 I'm kind of into this story so
I want to get back to it you're 28
you're starting to train for it what
happens you meet the wrong guy is that
what ends up happening so
Audrey
were you the wrong guy no I sometimes
you hang out with the wrong wrong crowd
long enough you become the wrong crowd
right yeah you are the wrong crowd
that's gonna happen soon in the story
but but you now that in several
different points because you said you
know about what happened in college I
couldn't live life on life's terms Gary
and that's one of the Hallmarks of being
an addict right but but when you do
something like I did you start getting
into all these different drugs and
alcohol a lot and you're an addict
that's a dangerous game you're playing
because now you become an addict and
you're in your addiction and in 2004 I
was in my addiction I I partied cocaine
was my drug of choice back then
but it was one day at work in 2004 I'm
passed out of sleep this other stock
broker comes up he sees me sleeping and
he wakes me up he's visibly shaken and
he's like he's like Damon wake up he
said you can't sleep on this job he said
dude the stock markets are open you're
messing with people's money they're
gonna they're gonna fire you he said
come on down the parking garage I've got
something that'll pick you up so I get
up out of my desk I follow this guy down
the parking garage it was nice little
sports car I believe we're gonna do a
little blow but when we get into the car
he hands me this glass pipe with these
crystal rocks in it
Gary I've never seen the classified
before I mean what is that and he's like
Damon just relax he said it's crystal
meth he said you're gonna love this
stuff
truer words have never been spoken Gary
I fell in love with Crystal Method it
was the most evil most destructive most
addictive drug I've ever put in my body
man I smoked it one time I was instantly
hooked just like that and I gave
everything away for that drug because
Gary that's what addicts do addicts give
things away addicts give up their goals
to meet their behaviors now and when I'm
talking about addiction there for
everybody listening I'm not just talking
about drugs and alcohol that's the
obvious addiction we talk about addicted
to anything food money clothing shopping
sex the internet social media whatever
it is you're addicted to if it takes you
away from the most important things in
life you give away your goals to get
there
but uh you know so when I started giving
away everything I gave away my job first
then it was how fast how fast I want to
get content 18 months I was living on
the streets of Dallas homeless
that I heard earlier take it back you go
in the pipe that day
do you do crystal meth the next day with
that dude oh I was up for four days the
first time I did it I mean I was a I
mean I was doing it every day after that
and and here's the deal and how quickly
did you lose that job because of it yeah
about a month about a month here and
here's why I lost the job too because
whenever he's whenever I get introduced
to meth I'm in the middle of studying
for my series seven and my series 63. my
interest exams to being a broker yep man
there's no more studying that goes on I
fail my series seven and my series 63
they bring me the office and the guy
that hired me got him Charlie eldemeyer
a family friend of my dad's he brought
me in he's like Damon is everything okay
I'm like and I'm high as a kite I'm like
yeah man everything's great Charlie he
said well you failed your exams he said
you're fired he said there's nothing I
can do for you Damon and they walked me
out of the office Gary I left that day I
got into my car and I called the guy up
I said I need your dealer because I just
got off early today I I looked at it as
getting off early man I went and got
high again Gary brother let me ask you a
question because I think this is a
common thing
you know just listened carefully there I
heard some of the stuff you know
Congress somebody ran for president
correct me if I'm wrong
given the religion of sports in this
part of the country which I love because
I'm a sports I'm addicted to sports so I
need to be you know the New York Jets
are going to put me into ruins um
it sounds like your dad was able to have
a lot of nice relationships that he
earned over his life that he was able to
really set you up with some and maybe
it's your mom like I don't know like it
sounds like your family was able to
create some door opening Not only was
your Gift of Gab there but it would also
like talk to me about the process of
like taking your parents for granted
with entitlement and when you're an
addict total entitlement Gary and I mean
let's call it for what it is I was a
privileged guy man I was one of those
privileged people that you could ever
meet man I had everything in my path
waiting for me there's a lot of
different ways to grow up in America
Gary and I had one of the most
privileged ways to grow up we weren't
rich or anything like that we were
middle class but man but the
relationships were there the
relationships and the relationships are
everything in life here are you talking
with us I talk about this with everybody
they're everything in life my dad had
built up relationships through all those
years in sports man and look being
around sports Gary I'm a sports nut too
we learned a lot of lessons in sports
and life Sports teaches us how to win
how to lose how to be part of a team
that's why it's why I'm petrified of
eighth place trophies if we eliminate
the losing and how to handle it we get
kids that are scared of everything but
Gary and we're going to get into this in
the story Sports didn't just teach me
those kind of lessons man my dad was the
first sports writer in Southeast Texas
to put black athletes on the front page
of sports Pages 1971 first time never
happened it was a black running back
from Lincoln High School named Joe
Washington Jr went on to play for the
Redskins for the Colts yeah Little Joe
well my dad puts Little Joe on the cover
of the sports page in 1971 people down
in the Southeast Texas lost their lives
over there they broke his windows they
sit his tires they sit and hate mail to
him
but when I was a little boy I was like
eight years old
my dad goes up in the attic one day he
comes down with this box with all these
envelopes these letters it's all the
hate mail
and he set me down as a kid that day and
he made me read every letter of hate
mail every nasty negative word that
people said about my father and my
mother because my dad puts a black guy
on the cover of Sports face but you know
what my dad told me back then he said
Damon I want you to see what it looks
like to take a stand and do the right
thing because he said sometimes taking a
stand and doing the right thing it means
you're gonna stand alone but but he said
it's always okay do you think that your
parents and again they sound so
wonderful so this will be hard but I'm
desperate to bring value and I see this
a lot and honestly I think it's a
challenge for me do you think it's
easier to kind of do the right things in
the world than necessarily do the right
things for your children because you
love them so much so you give them
inches and and Miles that you don't give
to others
yeah I think that people I said look
your girl I'll tell you from what I see
a lot people reach out to me a lot
because I'm a very visible person now
and people know that I'm in recovery I
get a lot of messages from parents whose
kids are suffering from addiction issues
uh or incarceration and and I have to
tell these parents the same thing every
time look I'll talk to your son your
daughter I believe that's one of the
reasons why I got out of prison I'll
I'll do that kind of service work all
day long I'll talk to anybody that
reaches out to me but I may be here to
talk to you because you as the parent
you are exhibiting addictive behavior
too you've become an addict you're
addicted to fixing somebody you can't
fix and when parents become the addict
because they're addicted to fixing their
kid it reminds me of my parents my
parents they would do anything to help
me out but sometimes doing those things
to help out a young person is not the
best thing for them you become an
enabler in the process and I think
that's where you're going with that my
parents that's exactly where I'm going
like I fear like by the way this is why
I wrote my last book to talk about
Candor I hate conflict with people I
love which leads into employees and I
create I'm an enabler you know people
love me like but you know but the
reality is I can enable bad behavior
because if I love you I you know garyvee
the public figures dominant because I'm
just talking to the world so I can draw
those lines in the sand and I can talk
about I can talk about these things but
as it gets closer to you know from an
acquaintance to a friend from a friend
to a good friend from a good friend to a
great friend to a best friend to family
it gets harder for me and I'm so
empathetic that I think everyone
listening right now can associate with
what we're saying now which is it's a
lot harder when it hits at home and with
a child there's nothing you love more
than that it's just the way it is
absolutely and it's you know
I think that like I said one of the
reasons why I even got out in the first
place is to be able to have these
difficult conversations because
it goes back to almost what you're
saying about the eighth place trophies
we are setting up an entire generation
for failure when we don't allow people
how to lose and learn tough lessons in
life but here's the trick you can also
lose and learn those tough lessons in
life you're a Gen X guy I'm a Gen X guy
man we grew up in a in a generation
where I mean and it's real popular on
social media right now everybody's
tagging that and hashtag and Gen X and
all that but but I mean look we we grew
up in a in a time where you could still
lose and you still had to you had to
communicate with people back when we
grew up Gary you didn't have phones if
you wanted to say something to somebody
you had to go you had to talk to him in
your face you had to have a little bit
of human interaction and right now
anti-social behavior is kind of like the
norm of what we're going to in this
country and it needs to come back to
where people are communicating with each
other in person we had the benefit of
that but you I'm saying that to say this
you can have all those things going for
you in life and I certainly did I had
everything going for me in life but you
can still go down that wrong road it's
like my dad told me with those letters I
was reading he said sometimes in life
you're going to have to take a stand
that's why I want you to read these
letters he said it's it's sometimes in
life you're going to have to stay on the
loan but he said it's always okay to
stand alone as long as you're standing
on the right side of History so it it
wasn't like I was raised by people who
didn't have a conscience of what was
going on my parents were in the middle
of the civil rights movement in the Deep
South and they they understood they got
it and my dad I mean my dad he explained
Sports to me at a young age he said
Damon before there was MLK there was
Jackie Robinson before you integrated
lunchrooms in the American South you
integrated locker rooms of course he
said Sports has the power to bring
people together like nothing else can
and that's what sports does do it's it's
it's why I've always associated with it
I think it's one of the great comps to
real life and it's why I'm passionate
about it my brother I know we bounced
around a ton and I know that that might
have gotten us off track in some places
in the last five minutes that we have
here together what have we not touched
on that you want to get to in this story
or a point that you feel will bring
value to The Listener let's go July 30th
2008 almost exactly 15 years from
recording of this episode I'm on the
couch that day I've got my meth dealer
sitting next to me and I'm telling this
his name is text my dope deal and I'm my
text you got to get out of here man the
cops are closing on me the end is near
and just about that time the window on
my right blows out and shatters and it's
a flashbang grenade Gary it's going
across my living room floor the thing
blows up in my face and when I came to
when I can see and hear again there's a
cop standing over me in full SWAT riot
gear man this bootles on my chest the
barrel of assault rifles digging in my
eye socket and he's screaming at me
don't move don't move and I'm like man
don't worry don't worry
and one of the cops came in screaming we
got him we got the Uptown burglar Gary I
went from being a Star College athlete
to this guy known as the Uptown burglar
they took me to Dallas County Jail that
day they processed me in I spent the
next 10 months in County Jail waiting
for my day in court and on May 18 2009 I
stood in front of a jury that sentenced
me to 65 years in the Texas Department
of Criminal Justice a life sentenced in
prison Gary and and right after the
trial was over my mom and my dad are
talking to me and my mom has this one
last visit with me Gary epic stuff and
she's like Damon you can't go off and
become someone we don't recognize she
said you owe Texas the debt of 65 years
you got to go and pay that debt you did
everything they said you did but here's
the debt you got to pay to us when you
go to prison you will not get in one of
these white hate groups one of these
Aryan Brotherhood type gangs you weren't
raised to be like that you weren't
raised to be a racist and she said you
come back as the man we raised Damon or
don't come back at all Gary I'm floored
man I don't know how I'm gonna do this
but but on the road waiting for my the
bus to come get me I'm two months I've
got to wait for the prison bus to come
get me I meet this guy in Dallas County
Jail this older black man this Muslim
guy named Mr Jackson and Mr Jackson
shares with me exactly how I'm gonna do
it he said imagine prison as a pot of
warm water he said you have three
choices how to respond in this potable
and water called life you can be like
the carrot that turns soft and mushy and
weak or an egg which becomes hard mad at
me you know the carrot goes in hard but
it becomes soft the egg goes in with a
soft liquid inside it's hard but the
heart becomes hardened he said or you
could be like a coffee bean because the
Coffee Bean changes the pot of warm
water into a pot of coffee he said the
coffee beans the only thing that will
change the water because it is a change
agent and the last words this guy said
to me before the prison bus is coming to
pick me up he looks at me he says West
be a coffee bean and Gary I remember how
I felt when he told me that I mean I
could get that man I can understand I
had three choices in this life and and I
go to prison Gary it's a baptism by fire
I mean the first two months of prison
are spent fighting my butt off man and
end up I end up Sports again Gary I end
up on the wreck yard earning respect out
there with those guys playing basketball
with them and so when the violence was
finally over the threat to my physical
safety was gone I got to work on myself
I became that coffee bean and seven
years later the parole board in Texas
comes to visit me and uh the lady from
parole interviews me in 2015 she says Mr
West
we don't see a lot of people like you
come through the system kind of the same
thing we've been talking about Gary she
said you had it all every Advantage
every privilege every opportunity she
said you're you're the definition of a
privileged person
she said but you didn't just change
yourself when you came to this prison
you changed the entire prison around you
she said so I have one question for you
today she said if you could be
remembered for being anything in life
anything at all she said tell me what
that would be in just one word go
hey Gary I breathe out and relax that's
an easy question for a coffee bean I
fired her answer back at her and I was
like ma'am
useful I just want to be useful you know
Gary I think everybody wants to be
useful you know and I told her I said I
just want to be useful man and I could
be useful inside this prison as you've
already seen or I could be useful in the
Free World again November 16 2015 Gary I
walked out of a Texas prison now I'm not
a free man when I walk out man I've got
a little more time left on parole in
Texas I'm on parole until the year 2073.
so from the recording of this episode
I've got 50 more years on supervised
release
I haven't let that hold me back Gary
meaning meaning if you do any version of
a slip up it's a wrap
yeah I mean it's they've got a short
leash on me every month I see my parole
officer in Beaumont Miss Braggs a pizza
cup I pay a fine I answer the questions
if I want to leave Texas uh I got to get
permission from Texas and but Gary look
man I'm a coffee bean the only way this
coffee Bean's going back to prison is
when I go to prisons All Over America
that's my passion man I go back into
prisons a lot because I'm the guy that
delivers hope in fact the inmates in
America they call me The Smuggler of
hope I smuggle hope into a place that's
hopeless you know the only way I go back
to prison is when I go on my own terms
and I walk out the front gate of all my
prisons but when I got out Gary I moved
back to Southeast Texas I lived with my
parents for the first two years on
parole
and I started sharing my story around
the area of Southeast Texas then uh The
Big Break happens you got a couple more
minutes Gary you're going to love this
story brother and everybody who's
listening is gonna be so pissed at me
everyone who's listening just to remind
you I am not a professional podcaster
like some of your other favorites I'm
already eight minutes late for a client
who just texted me saying basically what
the [__] so I'm not here even because
I'm captivated by this brother listen
everybody's listening it's not a super
hard name to look up d-a-m-o-n space
w-e-s-t if you've enjoyed this there's a
ton of content out there I thought this
would be a good uh a good conversation a
prospective gratitude parenting
entitlement accountability uh and
attachment to identification I hope you
took that out of it Damon we're cheering
for you brother keep building keep
coffee beaning it and I hope we cross
path soon bro be a coffee bean Gary take
care mama
thank you
[Music]